[Music]
all set
265 vaccination appointments booked
allow me to clarify
that's over 200 covid vaccine
appointments
booked by this guy hi i'm chris levins
i'm an unemployed it geek from new
jersey doing my best to secure covert
vaccine appointments for seniors in my
community
in case you haven't had the pleasure of
booking a coveted vaccine online
it can suck and not only for people who
aren't great at computers
i just found a coveted vaccine
appointment for an 80 year old family
friend on rite aid and then a couple of
minutes later
it was gone i just feel like i don't
know how to work the internet
the websites all differ they're hard to
navigate and appointments are
very limited honestly i'd equate it to
a joint sneaker release between beyonce
and cold play that included free concert
tickets
it's a shame but that's where we are due
to the fragmented roll
out chris first set out to book 71
appointments for seniors
71 for his father who passed away last
year at the age of 71
possibly from covet itself but after
chris had a booking system in place
he just kept going so i decided to go
study under the master
and get his best tips on booking
appointments
good nice to meet you nice to meet you
i'm chris
how intense is it in this world of
vaccine booking
right now we're at a point where
milliseconds matter
where that's why i always try and
suggest using a desktop or laptop
over a mobile phone and don't worry if
you don't live here in new jersey
i was able to use his tips to book
appointments in new york maryland
and florida plus i had chris highlight
specific tips for nationwide pharmacy
sites
such as rite aid and cbs okay on to the
tips
step one bookmark the websites and learn
the patterns
gather and bookmark the links to the
websites that allow you to make
appointments in your area
my best suggestion would be check your
state resources
or if there are facebook groups such as
ours in new jersey
we post every single availability in
real time
in some states there have been
aggregation sites built that list all
the vaccine locations
facebook groups can also be very helpful
for knowing the patterns when new
appointments are added
cbs i would always suggest checking at
5am to 6am that's when they load
appointments
for rite aid i would suggest always
checking at 11 50pm at night
do you sleep at all most recently
not a lot maybe two three hours a night
rite aid and cvs would not confirm those
appointment drop times
but i had similar luck at booking around
then step two
set up autofill in your web browser
you're able to
fill your address name phone number and
email address ahead of time
be it in chrome or any other web browser
you have so
when it comes time to click that booking
you can
automatically fill that information
without having to type it all in one go
all browsers have this in chrome go to
preferences
autofill addresses and more in microsoft
edge go to preferences personal info
in safari preferences autofill one thing
you cannot autofill
your insurance information but you can
skip putting that info in
all together on sites like rite aid and
cvs
step 3 set up browser extensions now
you're ready to book just the little
problem of figuring out when the
websites have appointments
two tools chris uses are necessary the
first
a browser refresh extension called page
refresh
this allows you to refresh the site
every few seconds or minutes without any
clicking
so you can see if it's been updated with
new appointment times
chris keeps these windows open on his
second monitor so he can see them
at all times this extension is available
for chrome and microsoft edge
and the developer clearly states the
extension doesn't collect
any user data keep the page refreshing
but make sure to also keep the extension
open so you could stop it in an instant
and get started on booking
if you don't hit stop it could refresh
the page and you could lose the
appointment opening
the second tool is really cool it's
called visual ping
you input a website and you tell it to
watch a certain part of it
an image or text if there's a change to
it
it will alert you with an email you can
also use the free web extension
and get alerted with a sound every
website will say
you know there are no appointments
available if you go in select that
element in visual ping
have it alert you when that's gone
you'll be able to score an appointment
easily
i did that on this website here and was
able to book an appointment that way
the downside is that you have to upgrade
to one of the higher tiers to have the
tool watch for changes to your site
every five minutes the web extension is
free
but you have to be at a computer to be
notified do you think that when we
publish this by next week you'll hit
300.
easily until it gets as easy to schedule
a covered vaccine shot as a flu shot i'm
going to be continuing
as rough as it is it's a good feeling to
be able to
get a senior an appointment who would
not have been able to otherwise